the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones season a Q&A video I want to
pick back up right where I left off in
my previous video today I want to
continue answering some of the questions
you left for me in my recent video I
gave you my opinion on what I thought
Game of Thrones could do to give us a
sad ending but in this video I'll be
covering multiple topics the first
question I want to answer was left by a
user who goes by the name of squid it
says what do you think will be the
opening scene for season 8 I want to
answer this question first because they
are asking about the opening scene so I
figured this is the perfect question to
open up a video I don't consider
anything to be fully confirmed until the
episode airs and we can see it for
ourselves
however there were reports from a few
reliable sources about this very topic a
few months ago Watchers on the wall
acquired some information about the
opening scene and their source says the
very first scene will take place just
outside of Winterfell in a small village
known as winter town we have seen this
town a few times already in the pilot
episode this is where Tyrion Lannister
was shacked up in the whorehouse when
Jamie came into the room telling him
about the Starks having a feast to
celebrate King Robert's arrival we also
saw this town in season five when
Brienne and Podrick were attempting to
rescue Sansa this is where Brienne
watched from a window hoping to get a
signal from sauna that would let her
know she needed rescued immediately the
reports I have read about the opening
scene do not go into all the details
about the scene all it basically gives
is the location as of right now I can
confirm or deny the report but I will
say Watchers on the wall does have
reliable sources I followed them closely
during season seven and pretty much
everything they said what happened did
happen so if I had to bet money on where
the opening scene would take place I
would say winter town is correct but of
course we will just have to wait and see
if this is accurate or not I'm sure some
of you might be wondering
why would they film the opening scene in
that location when we haven't seen any
characters in this town in quite some
time well I have a few guesses but keep
in mind it's just my opinion
Winterfell in the surrounding areas
should be fairly peaceful as of right
now that's until Brian stark breaks the
news about the night king breaching the
wall at eastwatch-by-the-sea I think the
opening scene of the first episode could
be showing us the calm before the storm
we could see everyone in winter town
preparing for winter or preparing for
battle last season we saw Shawn's are
walking around Winterfell and she was
given instructions about gathering food
and she was inspecting some of the armor
that was being made in the courtyard we
could see something very similar to this
in winter town even if there aren't that
many people there they would still have
to brace themselves for the winter and
if they know the night king is coming
they will have to brace themselves for a
hell of a lot more than that during that
scene with Sansa they gave us some
possible foreshadowing about what's to
come next season especially not of the
armies of the north come back to defend
Winterfell no milady most likely not and
we must prepare for that eventuality
whatever direction the threat comes from
this is the best place to be we need to
start building up our grain stores with
regular shipments from every keep in the
north we don't use it by winters end
we'll give it back to them but if the
entire North has to flee to Winterfell
they won't have enough time to bring
wagon loads of grain every soldier the
Starks have on their side will be
stationed at Winterfell they don't even
have enough food to feed every soldier
especially when you factor in all the
Dothraki and unsullied sons I said they
don't have enough food as of right now
but Winterfell is the best place to be
no matter which direction the threat
comes from she also knows it's a very
good possibility that everyone in the
north will flee to Winterfell for safety
which is one of the reasons why I always
said Winterfell would be ground zero for
the Great War against the night King
John and Daenerys will have to set up
camp for all these men outside of
Winterfell walls which means winter town
will become very busy next season when
the first episode begins we could see
Jon and Daenerys arriving in the north
and they will most likely set up camp
for Danny's armies all around the castle
and clue
winter town I hope Daenerys was able to
bring some food because I don't know how
they're gonna feed all these men
especially when you consider this could
be the longest winter in recent memory
given the fact that the night king is
coming and he typically brings the storm
and darkness with him now that the night
king is south of the wall this is
inevitable and if you remember old nan
story from the first season then you
should know just how desperate things
can get when it's extremely cold and
people are very hungry thousands of
years ago there came a night that lasted
a generation Kings froze to death in
their castles same as the Shepherd's in
their huts and women smothered their
babies rather than see them starve and
wept and felt the tears freeze on their
cheeks let's move on to the next
question this one is from a Shack and
this is the question that had the most
likes it says why has in john told
Daenerys about maester aemon this is a
good question but the only thing I can
do is take a guess it is possible that
the writers may have just forgotten to
mention this or they did not have enough
time in season seven because they were
already having to rush so many things
already or did John decide to keep this
information to himself for a reason you
would think given how close John and
Eamon were this could have helped him in
Damaris build a relationship and trust a
lot sooner now that I think about it
tyrion also met maester aemon when he
was at the wall and he's never mentioned
it either if I had to guess I would say
they are saving this for a later time
you have to keep in mind John was in a
hurry to get that dragon glass because
he knew it was only a matter of time
before the night King made his way south
then John got word that arya and bran
were alive and they made it home so he
may have had some other things on his
mind but I think John and Daenerys will
have a discussion about maester aemon
next season because if you remember what
Eamon said to John back in season 1 I
believe this will have a very big
influence on John's decision-making in
the final season
my father was Micah the first of his
name
my brother Aegon reigned after him when
I had refused and throne and he was
followed by his son Aerys whom they
called the Mad King Aemon Targaryen John
knew that Maester Aemon had the
opportunity to take the Iron Throne for
himself but he chose to go to the wall
instead when John finds out he's
actually Aegon Targaryen the true heir
to the Iron Throne I believe he will do
exactly what maester aemon did no I
don't think he'll go back to Castle
black but he will pass his right to the
Iron Throne to the next person in line
maester aemon wanted to be a maester but
he also had no interest in politics nor
did he want to become rivals with his
brother so he stepped aside and he
allowed his brother to have the position
I think John will do the same thing with
Daenerys assuming they are both alive at
the end once John is revealed to be the
true heir to the Iron Throne people will
expect him to take the position but John
has never wanted to run the Seven
Kingdoms this is something Daenerys is
fighting for and John knows that Maester
Aemon was a very wise man and he always
knew there would come a day when John
would have to choose what is honor
compared to a woman's love what is Duty
against the feel of a newborn son in
Europe sooner or later in every man's
life there comes a day when it is not
easy a day when he must choose and this
is my day a man's words will echo
throughout the final season and one of
the biggest decisions John will ever
have to make so John might not have
mentioned Damon when he first met
Daenerys but a man's counsel will have a
big influence over John next season they
may not have had time to add a scene
with John and Daenerys talking about a
maan but they might be saving it for
Season eight one this discussion could
have a very big impact on the last
episode of the series the next two
questions come from Jane EB
the first one says we'll go survive and
the second one says will Sansa betray
John good question because I know
everyone has been wondering where the
hell is ghost
I think the fate of ghost is pretty
simple whatever is meant to happen with
John will happen to ghost if John
survives the entire series then so will
ghost but if John is meant to die in the
end
then ghost will die too the fate of the
Starks have always been connected to the
direwolves that's why their names have
such significance to their stories I
happen to think John will live and pass
up his opportunity to take the Iron
Throne like I said in the previous
question so this would mean ghost lives
too in my opinion however I would not be
surprised if they killed Jon Snow for
good I'm already expecting some of my
favorite characters to die and John
could be one of them hopefully we get to
actually see ghosts next season he might
as well be dead because he's never in
any damn scenes anyway even though
ghosts should always be a John side but
I do understand they have to cut out
certain things because of the budget we
may not see ghost than any of the
upcoming battles but I believe he will
be a John side in the finale now your
second question is a little more
complicated
well Sansa betray John I would say no I
cannot see Sansa outright betraying John
especially now that Sansa and Arya have
seemed to work things out with one
another Sean's they even set herself
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
Sansa
Arya and bran took down Littlefinger
together so I think songs is learning
that she needs her family right now and
John is a part of that family no matter
what his name is on the other hand I do
believe there will be some tension next
season when John shows up with Daenerys
and her dragons this will definitely
cause some problems respect I must agree
with Lady Sansa
I remember the Mad King all too well a
Targaryen cannot be trusted nor can a
Lannister
[Applause]
we called your brother King and then he
rode south I lost his kingdom
Wednesday is his your grace we need the
King in the north
in the north they didn't want John going
down to meet Daenerys in the first place
and now he's bringing her right into
their backyard this is gonna piss a lot
of people often the north in John and
Sansa could bump heads next season
because of this but I don't think it
will lead to songs of betraying him
I actually think John will give up his
position and Winterfell as well moving
the lost Chamber prepared for you mother
and father's ring you should take it I'm
nice dog you ask me
you're the lady at Winterfell you
deserve it was done here because you saw
ins a has-been the lady of Winterfell
since John left and I think he will tell
her to keep the title and position John
will obviously play a big part in
strategizing for the battle against the
night King and Cersei and he'll probably
even lead those battles but at the end
of the series
I could see Sansa taking control of
Winterfell for good the next question
comes from Flaherty
and it says in season 2 episode 5 Tywin
asked Arya what they say about Robb in
the north and Arya says he rides a giant
direwolf into battle and he can turn
into a wolf himself will re a ride into
battle or Nymeria will bran teacher -
warg into a wolf I wanted to answer this
question also because just like with
ghost people want to know if we will
ever see Nymeria again I don't know if
we'll see REO riding on her back but I
do think Nymeria and our Wolf Pack could
have a role to play in the books Arya
already knows how to warg into Nymeria
but I don't think they're gonna have her
do that in the show because they never
set it up in previous seasons now on the
other hand bran Stark could always warg
into the wolf pack and bring them north
the same way he does with the Ravens he
is able to continuously switch from bird
to bird until he gets them all to the
location he wants to look at and he
could do the same with numerius pack
during an interview george RR martin
said Nymeria and her pack would show up
later in the books so maybe they will do
the same thing in the show or at least I
hope so George said you know I don't
like to give things away says Martin a
grin spreading across his face but you
don't hang a giant wolf pack on the wall
unless you intend to use it so as you
can see george RR martin plans on using
the dire wolves at some point so there
is still a chance we could see them in
battle in the show
I don't think Arya will ride on her back
but I do think we will see them at least
one more time before it's all said and
done Game of Thrones has the biggest
budget in television history
and I hope they do spend a few dollars
on these damn dire wolves before it's
too late let me know what you think
about Nymeria and ghosts do you think we
will see them again and do you think
they will survive also what do you think
about the opening scene
if it's in winter town what would they
be filming in that location put your
thoughts or questions down below in the
comment section I want to thank you all
for watching the video I'll really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
everyone on patreon for supporting the
channel thank you very much and have a
great day
I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you